echémosle un vistazo a la canasta de
bienes y servicios con respecto al ipc
guión o índice de precios al consumidor
urbano aquí tenemos una tabla este es un
reporte emitido por las oficinas
estadísticas del trabajo tu puedes
investigar los puedes investigar al ipc
onu oa estas oficinas como tú puedes ver
esta es la tabla 1 es el primer reporte
que dan y dice el índice de precios al
consumidor para todos los consumidores
urbanos como puedes ver también cuando
se refieren al ipc normalmente se
refieren a estos a los urbanos porque la
mayoría de los consumidores caen en esta
categoría entonces dice promedio en
ciudades de eeuu por categoría de gastos
mercancía y grupos de servicio luego
definen un año base el año base en 1982
luego toman un rango del 82 al 84 toman
el promedio ahí y dicen que es de 100 o
al menos que se indique lo contrario y
bueno veamos que tenemos aquí en esta
columna tenemos las diferentes
categorías en las que el consumidor
urbano podría gastar su dinero dice la
canasta de bienes y servicios en la cual
un poco
menos del 15% es gastado en comida y
bebidas luego el porcentaje va bajando
13% en comida en comida luego un poco
menos del 8% en comida en casa luego
seriales carnes bla bla bla las frutas
verduras entonces el promedio según
según se ve la canasta parece ser que
gastan lo mismo en frutas y verduras que
en alcohol eso es muy interesante muy
interesante no sé si sea malo o bueno
pero pero es interesante esta aguja es
muy interesante esta hoja de la canasta
para un consumidor urbano promedio y te
deja ver te deja ver lo que están
gastando te deja ver que están gastando
un poco más en en lo que es carne y
pescado y los porcentajes van bajando
van bajando desde lo que se compra más a
lo menos guau 41 por ciento en casas
guau 31 por ciento en lo general al
hogar todo lo que requieras para vivir
pues cómodamente aquí también tenemos lo
que es gas gas y utilidades y también 4%
en lo que son muebles me encantan los
muebles a mí me encantan
sigamos bajando aquí aquí está
interesante este asunto vamos a ver qué
más dice
el consumidor urbano promedio gasta aquí
vemos este 3.6 por ciento en vestimenta
me encanta la ropa 17 por ciento en
transporte 6.6 por ciento en cuidados
médicos la misma cantidad más o menos en
recreación también igual en educación y
sigue así bajando esto bajan los
porcentajes veamos qué más hay
hay muchas categorías aquí también por
ejemplo un poco menos del 1 por ciento
gastan en lo que es cigarros y tabaco
entonces tú dices bueno no mucha gente
fuma en estos tiempos pero si ponemos 1
de cada diez que fuman todos ellos los
que sí fuman con ellos obtendremos el
promedio de aproximadamente el 1 por
ciento en la canasta y bueno así como tú
puedes ver hay muchas categorías hay
mucho hay mucho que ver aquí mucho
muchos datos muy muy interesantes y
bueno todas estas ponderaciones
combinadas veamos que la suma total es
de vamos a ver cuánto cuánto cuánto
cuánto aquí está es de 100 es de 100 esa
es la canasta de bienes total y esta
columna de aquí es la ponderación dice
aquí está la ponderación total en
diciembre de 2010
hay que tener claro que todo cambia las
personas cambian sus hábitos productos
salen a la venta productos cambian de
precio debemos tener un ponderado
debemos ver cuáles son los cambios en
los precios y cuál es el promedio de los
porcentajes ahora recordemos aquí lo que
dice dice que al menos se indique lo
contrario nuestro año base tendrá 100
tendrás 100 luego relativo a ese año nos
dan los precios de índice para cada
categoría noviembre de 2011 diciembre
2011 luego averiguan su cambio de
porcentaje in ajustado al diciembre 2011
de diciembre del año previo como puedes
ver aquí luego el mes previo noviembre
2011 como puedes notar el cambio del año
previo es mayor que el cambio del mes
previo a ver vamos a examinar un poco
esto dice en noviembre de 2011 en
noviembre de 2011 la comida y la bebida
en promedio fueron aproximadamente 2.3
por ciento más caras que en los años
entre el 82 y el 84 ahora dice acá
también en diciembre
aquí dice en diciembre 2011 fueron
aproximadamente 2.31 por ciento más
caros que en el rango del 82 al 84 ahora
veamos aquí este otro dato curioso esta
línea de aquí dice que en el 67 1967 era
de 100 dice que todos los artículos
fueron de 2.26 por ciento más caros que
en el 82 el 84 ahora tomando como el año
base al 67 en 1967
tenemos el siguiente dato tenemos 6
puntos 77 por ciento más caro que en ese
año ahora aquí tomamos como año base a
1967 y vemos que 6.77 más caro con
respecto a ese año igual no podemos
seguir aquí de curiosos bajando por
todas las categorías viendo a ver qué
onda está bastante interesante tomando
el 82 como año base estamos viendo qué
tan caro se ha vuelto todo aquí tenemos
por ejemplo muebles no han subido tanto
de precio relativo de los 80s
tenemos categorías que han bajado de
precios por ejemplo aquí tenemos
vehículos nuevos y viejos vehículos como
ves no ha cambiado mucho y bueno tú
dirás oye pero mi carro yo gasto mucho
en el gasto mucho más en el que en el 82
y de hecho si tienes razón pero hay
ajustes que se les hacen a los carros
que en aquellos años ahora no se les
hacen o sea relativamente más o menos
ahí andan en los mismos precios pero por
otro lado cosas como atención médica
guau ha subido mucho de precio desde los
80 es cuatro veces más caro como tú
puedes ver agua a veces mucho audio y
vídeo ha bajado de precio y recreación
en general no ha subido mucho ahora aquí
procesamiento de información bajó de
precio también servicios telefónicos no
subieron tanto comunicación bajo de
presión de hecho esto de llamar a una
persona desde aquellos años en deja muy
caro ahora es dramáticamente más barato
computadoras personales las computadoras
personales también bajaron de precio y
también al igual que los carros se les
hacen ajustes
como el hecho de que ahora las
computadoras personales son más
poderosas y bueno me parece muy
divertido estar aquí de curiosa viendo
datos interesantes muy interesantes por
ejemplo este de aquí el tabaco subió de
precio dramáticamente esta tabla del ipc
urbano tiene información muy interesante
aquí tenemos la categoría de mercancías
y servicios
sabes muchas de estas cosas déjala bajo
un poco para que se vea toda completa
aquí está muchas de estas cosas están en
un rango de 1 2 o 3 % pero cosas como
servicios médicos y tabaco son mucho más
caras ahora en cambio computadoras y
comunicación son ahora más baratas y
bueno como lo mencioné antes esto mide
el cambio de porcentaje de diciembre
2011 al año previo y tenemos aquí al mes
previo y bueno quedan pendientes estas
columnas y aquí estas son los cambios de
porcentaje ajustado según las temporadas
lo ver en otro vídeo así que bueno nos
vemos pronto
bye